thank you
[Music]
take a look at this photo and then just
tell me how it makes you feel
first Jason
um I it's very 2023 of uh yeah it's good
what do you guys think
what's happening [__] already
proposal she's asking him to marry her
yeah is that Venice
uh yeah oh is that a little dog I don't
know it looks like it could be the Grove
or Bellagio have you been to Venice wait
there's a little dog looking up like
that that's pretty cute uh yeah but like
what do you think about females
proposing to male Colleen what do you
think about that is he gonna take her
last name
uh because I think
okay let's type if there's a benefit I
feel like I'm traditional and that looks
weird to me yeah I think that looks fun
yeah I see that and I get angry I get
mad you think she likes it rough in bed
you know what there's a chance I think
he likes it rough from her and bad he
has a ponytail for a reason perhaps his
legs around her in bed yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'm a Jalen fence the kind of guy
that's aspiring to be a house Dad could
be yeah yeah he's the kind of guy that
packs her lunch so she goes to work and
he comes back cleans and he takes a
little break has a nice apron on dude
with a little with a glass of wine and
he drinks like this you ever meet a
house dad they're never happy dude
really ever no bro I just feel like
women who are proposing to men like that
is because they so desperately want to
get married and they their boyfriend is
asking them so it's like they're trying
to take it upon themselves to do that
okay but I just feel like you're just
trying to pigeonhole them or force them
into a situation that if they wanted to
do that they would have already done it
that's a pretty thing you don't think
that's women empowerment or now women
can also dress too so that's pretty ding
ding ding in my opinion yeah because I
have a friend that where it was in three
engagements
um she proposed all three times she
proposed three men he's 20 23. wait
she's proposed to three men yeah and all
three of them didn't work out yeah oh
she proposed to this man she proposed to
another man this dude together two years
didn't work out oh new love of my life
together didn't work out oh and you
would love in my life initiate it it's a
it's a trap move I think I think what
yeah I think what she's saying is like
they dream of this scenario they want
this so badly that it's not happening at
their time frame that they want it to
yeah so they're gonna go ahead and push
it further yes and then so they're like
well if you're not gonna do it I'll do
it because there's guys that do that too
where they're like uh I'm just gonna try
to keep this girl forever and then she's
kind of on the fence and then they'll do
like a proposal and the girls can't say
no so they'll just say yes on both sides
it happens on both sides but yeah but
then in these cases it's because of that
you're saying like most of it is
probably that I think so I mean it'd be
interesting see if there's any like
how many like
divorces in just those situations if
they like pull women who've proposed to
those men
too like if do they know like beforehand
it's like oh one day she's gonna propose
to him just in the time or if it's just
like out of the blue and he's like yeah
he's just like oh my God yeah
she's playing something I don't know
what it is I'm going to my favorite
restaurant
can I see the picture again I gave her
so many hints throughout the week it's
not what's in a real one oh was it no
but was that just like a stock photo
that was a stock photo that looked
because that was so perfect yeah it was
like it's almost like they actually
rehearsed it's a great picture but I
think the guy campaign is AI generated
it's a stock photo because
it could happen often enough time
because I think the guy's not really
happy in that picture he doesn't look
that like thrilled because I think like
most chips still want to get taken care
of and then so being proposed to is kind
of part of that whole thing I don't know
any of these like modern relationship
things that work
I don't know anyone with that it's hard
because we also typically don't have
friends that believe that are gay I mean
okay yeah yeah but like
but even if there's like um like let's
say there's a lesbian couple yeah
usually there's one that's a little bit
more masculine than the other one uh-huh
the more masculine one is the one that
proposes too which is kind of strange
right when you think it's it's like
there's like so whether regardless of
what
biological gender is yeah there is like
this duality in a relationship where one
is like more nurturing and the Mars
protector is a natural gender role
people just don't want to say it like
that because it's so like Politically
Incorrect but also it's like generally
The Protector is the one that proposes
to the nurturer yeah it's so cool that
the protector is proposing because you
would think that the nurturer will be
like hey would you have me
the nursery would propose yeah because
the new dream will be like would you
help me protect me like that but then
will you be my protector yeah that's
cool though yeah when you say like who
they want to protect that's what makes
it sweet because
I'm not
this is basically uh like the modern
more liberal way of seeing it yeah and
the reason for it is that they don't
want gender roles to be so male Chosen
and male driven from the start so advice
that they give to women is to be the
proposer so that the playing field is
not necessarily all against your favor
but I feel like
that's the logic there I'm not saying
that if that's what they say okay and it
happens to work out great good for them
if me and Jill were dating yeah and then
all of a sudden she got on one knee and
then behind her was like a 67 Chevelle
and that's my ring on my [__] yeah
all right all right I see what you're
doing
okay okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
that makes sense she's like proposing
with the ring that she wants for herself
yeah can you can you put this back on me
after yeah I think Bart has to get lower
it might actually be what's difficult is
if you're like a liberal couple and you
believe in that then you almost have to
let your girl propose right because you
don't want to be commandeering that job
as the man but the people that are
giving this advice how many of them are
in a successful marriage where they
got proposed it says all all of them
because dude people love to give advice
about marriage all the time unsolicited
you know and also too it's like they're
talking from a place where their
relationship sucks all the time I would
know because I give advice all the time
so I I understand I know my own you know
I feel like the kind of guys that get
proposed to when they get kissed by
their like fiance's they're the ones
that kick their foot out
yeah
what if opposed to you what how would it
catch you off guard oh 100
because like part of it is like damn
well in the moment if I'm trying to
think if she actually got down to one
even proposed to me part of me would be
like flattered that like oh my gosh he
wants to marry me that's kind of cool
initiative she took the initiative to do
it but the other side of me unwillingly
is like no no get the [__] up like
that's crazy I should be the one doing
that but you wake up though okay because
you're a nice person yeah but I don't
know we probably have to have a
debriefing about it like we'd have to
have us we'd have to talk about it
afterwards like
um can you not post this on social media
it's gonna ruin my reputation I also
think they're like guys we like that
like as a male in general like we like
to chase and then so but if you're like
hey I'm here you got me I don't know I
don't know if I like that
yeah I want to be like we've had like 12
years of practice of like in elementary
middle school high school of asking
girls to dances right like that core
yeah it's like a repetition thing but
then you you know when she likes you
back it's not they chase two but they do
a different kind of Chase they just make
it easy they dangle the carrot they're
just like you're just like oh I'm
accidentally here and you're like ah are
you you're here yeah you're making it
easy for me that's so cool you know it's
like different it's hard to understand
because obviously we've all Grown Up In
traditional gender role examples but it
is interesting to think that like like
in my situation like I've been with my
girl for like eight eight years I should
I'd probably even propose pretty soon
but if she were to do it if she were to
beat me to it I could honestly say we
would probably break up because it would
weird me the [__] out no way because not
a character I think so yeah I think it's
just it would just be but then I'm also
scum for taking so long but like at the
same time it's like it would be so
off-putting to me that I don't think I
could continue in whatever if with that
being a foundation with that being the
new does she know that yeah she would
never do that like that's but that's
also why it would be weird because she's
not like that either perfect prank for
Ryan yeah I know I was just thinking
it's like pranks
you're gonna break yourself over Frank
but yeah would you could you ever
imagine yourself proposing to anybody
Colleen
nobody ever
no no
even if he was with you for eight years
well well what if he just wants that one
thing but everything is great he's just
like oh I just like it if you would he
verbally says I want to be proposed to I
don't think we would need to be dating
yeah
he's like can you propose to me and walk
me through the threshold
you're like okay what if he just sends
you ring sizes
card magazines of the Rings that he
wants oh my this is my ring baby
[Laughter]
he goes oops dropped into Beer's catalog
you know what I think is fair
if the chick proposes then for the rest
of our lives you asked me what I want to
eat and I say anything
when you say something I thought oh no
not that one yeah then I think it's okay
nice
the rest of my life anything honey and
your conscious dinging the curb with the
hubcap of your car